bonsoir véronique lecoq merci d'être
avec nous à la manifestation aujourd'hui
on pouvait lire sur les banderoles
l'agriculture française subit un énorme
plan social organisé dans le plus grand
silence
parlez nous de ce plan social ce sont
quoi les vents trop souvent à perte
bonsoir à tous disons pourquoi ce
message les fermes qui ferment ce top
aux fermes qui ferment et pourquoi ça
doit s'adresser au parisien pourquoi d
une campagne d'affichage dans les métros
parce que ce que nous subissons les
parisiens le subissent aussi quelque
part et ils ne savent pas que les fermes
ferme et il faut qu'on leur explique
qu'en des fermes ferment ce sont des
exploitants qui ne produisent plus et
c'est une forme de délocalisation qui
s'est par exemple si je prends l'exemple
de des asperges
il y a 20 ans on produisait en france
dix mille hectares là même la même
surface qu'en allemagne
en allemagne on produit aujourd'hui
vingt-deux mille hectares en france on
ne produit plus que 4000 hectares c'est
cette forme de délocalisation qui est le
résultat d'une politique de prix ne
couvrent en plus nos coûts de production
expliquez-nous véronique le flop parce
que c'est intéressant ce que vous nous
dites justement vous dites voilà dans
les villes les parisiens où les autres
c'est très important parce que c'est une
bonne alimentation
les produits locaux qui
de ne pas très loin de chez nous
explique edmond justement cela la france
à son agriculture qui a été classée pour
la troisième année consécutive comme
étant la plus durable au monde et cette
agriculture elle peut pas se faire sans
agriculteur est aujourd'hui en fait le
ratio qui fait que pour une exploitation
derrière chaque exploitation il y à cet
emploi ce sont sept emplois rémunérés
alors même que les agriculteurs ne le
sont plus et l'origine de ce malaise
c'est d'abord la politique et je dirais
même la politique européenne puisque en
92 avec cette politique de soutien à
l'agriculture pour nous faire produire à
des prix mondiaux fait que on a lancé
tout un commerce et que nos industriels
se sont justement inscrit dans une
logique de commerce avant une logique de
souveraineté autant avec les pays tiers
on a pu commercer en commerce c'est plus
de 180 milliards exportés avec une
balance positive de 60 milliards donc ça
c'est l'europe et avec les pays tiers et
la france c'est tout aussi bénéfique
par contre cette politique européenne
avec des échanges intra européen qui
pèse pour près de 330 milliards fait que
des français mangent des produits
d'ailleurs d'europe et nos bons produits
français ceux issus de l'agriculture la
plus durable se trouve ailleurs mais là
où on est perdant c'est bien parce que
nous nous avons une agriculture qui
répondent à des normes supérieures et
nous avons aussi un coût horaire qui est
bien supérieur at on aujourd'hui
clairement quand on vous écoute les
moyens de ce protectionnisme
comment expliquer justement que la
france subisse
une réglementation plus stricte alors
qu'on est au sein de l'ordre qui nous
permet manifestement pas de protéger les
agriculteurs français
c'est un peu contradictoire est plus
tout à fait je dirais plutôt pourquoi
les politiques nous laisse justement
entre dans dans ce marché mondialisé
mais qui finalement est très pénalisant
déjà au sein de l' europe 1 si je vous
donne l'exemple de la viande les
quantités de viande exporté en frais par
la france 1 près de 200 mille tonnes
ce sont les mêmes quantités qui sont
importés franchement tout ça devrait
être davantage encadré pour que nos
industriels et là je vise aussi bien les
industriels privés que les industriels
coopératif privilégie la matière
première française
il n'y a pas assez de pression des
différents gouvernements parce que voilà
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on parle de
ce débat c'est un débat qui ne semble
pas se terminer ça veut dire que tous
les gouvernements successifs de droite
comme de gauche ne font pas assez pour
l'agriculture française
en fait ce qu'ils ne font pas c'est un
calcul pour mettre en parallèle chacune
des productions pour les ondes exportent
et je pense par exemple aux céréales
comme vous le montrer juste à l'instant
pour laquelle la balance commerciale est
bénéficiaire de 5 milliards d'euros
mais face à ces 5 milliards on a quand
même donné près de trois milliards
d'euros aux producteurs français aux
céréaliers et et finalement c'est comme
si on exportait ses aides
donc la france fait de mauvais calculs
et c'est pas faute de le répéter et
l'acr justement la coordination rurale
veut informer les consommateurs pour
justement que ce soit les produits
français qu'ils soient transformés dans
nos industries françaises pour d'abord
être commercialisé au niveau français
est ce que le consommateur a un rôle à
jouer
dans cette affaire comment petit vous
aider le consommateur finalement là le
consommateur peut d'abord dénoncé au
même titre que nous le faisons ensuite
son acte d'achat
il ne peut acheter que ce que ce que lui
et ce qui lui est proposé
donc quand on sait que la france exporte
beaucoup de volaille et on en importe
beaucoup aussi
mais d'ailleurs d'europe et beaucoup de
des copains si bien que le consommateur
a une chance sur deux d'acheter un
poulet d'un port à chaque fois qu ils en
achètent et c'est ça qui doit être
davantage encadré pour justement
produire les produits qu'on ne veut plus
importer on regarde d'abord le produit
pour le consommateur et c'est aux
consommateurs mais je pense qu'il le dit
assez sauf qu'il est impuissant face à
ce qu'il a dans les rayons oui un autre
un autre motif de manifestations
aujourd'hui qui rejoint évidemment tout
ce qu'on dit puisque son nez la terrible
conséquence 372 suicide d'exploitants
agricoles recensés en 2015 ce sont les
chiffres les plus récents que vous
possédez c'est immense ça paraît
incroyable ça fait plus d'un suicide par
jour j'ai des agriculteurs alors le
malaise il a été pris en charge la par
un député olivier damaisin qui en a fait
un rapport qui aboutit à une conclusion
des quatre aires alors je voulais
citerai pas mais en tout cas ils
demandent du réconfort
il oublie juste une chose c'est la
responsabilité dans son rapport bien
qu'il nous est aussi auditionné il ne
condamne pas les responsables des
suicides chez les agriculteurs
or nous agriculteurs nous sommes
à la merci de tous les industriels des
banquiers et nous sommes un secteur qui
qu'on ne peut pas cesser ou faire cesser
comme un menuisier ou à un maçon on a
une structure dans laquelle on ne peut
faire que de l'agriculture si bien qu'on
a des coopératives
on a des banques on a beaucoup de
partenaires qui continuent à nous
soutenir abusivement en nous prêtant
beaucoup plus d'argent qu'on a besoin
qu'on a investi les coopératives qui
continue à nous avancer de la
marchandise des aliments justement pour
récupérer le produit ce que ce soit le
lait ou autre chose et ce soutien abusif
la devrait être condamnée pour ne pas
nous laisser nous endetter et et finir
justement plutôt que des liquides et
finir au bout d'une corde
merci véronique le fleuve vice
présidente de la coordination rurale
avoir été avec nous